what is up reject nation
i'm greg i'm john we're gonna watch the
falcon and the winter soldier
episode four today last we left off with
io i believe is her name or ayo also
zemo
mm-hmm former echo scorpion
sokovian covert kill squad apparently
last week was it was not a good idea to
barely sleep
take a flight jet back home to watch
[ __ ]
i mean that he completely slipped on his
background that was mentioned
briefly in captain america's civil war
when tony stark is
on his little plane slash helicopter
thingamajig
jet all right don't worry someone will
correct with that one yeah
there you go do it i don't care thanks
to eric over at nerd chronic for editing
the reaction highlights for us in this
video thank you to everyone who
subscribed and clicked the notification
bell and hit the like button full length
watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code or over at our patreon page
we're over there we cover so many shows
with the same team you get the option
for reaction highlights and
watch logs included for a whole
gazillion you know you guys if this is
the fourth episode all right if you know
the truth you know
we're not the only reactors that do this
just i think one of the few reactors who
has you know reaction highlights as well
for exclusive shows over
at patreon because um there's less you
gotta
deal with come watch jojo's bizarre
event that's where everyone watches us
[Music]
we're going to a condo whoa i should
have called it out dude
it is time oh wow
how cool
learning to discipline himself with work
through the words
homecoming
you're free
that's so cool
oh wow [ __ ]
my man that's a great scene my man
[Music]
just working through the demons
it's got hope icona
and we come for him calling him the
white wolf
so we've got a semo you got eight hours
to be a good guy
okay eight hours to prove yourself well
the wakandas are here
they want zemo
i have the will to complete this mission
do the two of you
she's just a kid she's a supremacist the
very concept of a super soldier will
always trouble people
aspiration that led to nazis to altrum
to the avengers hey those are our
friends you're talking about the
avengers
not the nazis carly he was in world war
ii
she will not stop she will escalate
until
you kill her oh oh she kills you
serum never corrupted steve touche
but there has never been another steve
rogers has there
ah john walk john moore
[Laughter]
you heard of donya madani
no sir no
they all just left the room yep
turkish delight
was always my son's favorite don't trust
the witch
i would like to pay my last respects
do you know where a funeral will be
wow zemo is so smart
everyone lays down the whole package the
hell is he going
he's getting the information that you
guys can get yeah
he said he wouldn't get in your way
they're very bad not to be trusted
tonya is our little secret okay oh
[ __ ] um for five years
people have been welcomed into countries
that have kept them out using barbed
wire
folks were happy to have people around
to help them rebuild and then boom
just like that it goes right back to the
way it used to be
she's not motivated by the same things
can i understand your opposition you
know the door is coming for you
any minute in fact to probably lurking
outside right now i prefer to keep my
leverage
oh don't engage him he's just going to
extort you into that stupid head tilt
thing
let me make a call oh the winter soldier
rage
he has to see him sweat a little bit
yeah the cinematography in this show is
on
point seriously my grandfather lucas
you always used to tell me if you're
doing something and it makes you scared
it's probably because it's the right
thing it depends
it's just there's discretion involved
i didn't think there could be another
captain america until i met you
wow that's a compliment what we're doing
what outlives the legacy of that shield
that shield is a monument to a bygone
era if anything that shield should be
destroyed
just the way people kind of talk about
things today yeah
carly morgan thought it was too
dangerous for you guys to be pulling
this [ __ ]
so rude now oh this better be an
unbelievable explanation take it easy
before it gets weird
i know where carly is he's just walking
around as captain america
hey guys shield it's me
i used to counsel soldiers dealing with
trauma okay this is right in my
wheelhouse
yeah way back to winter soldier
john walker just like i just want to be
captain america man so over this just
respect me what i do remember is being
alone
like a lot of you hear mamadonia saved
me
she clothed me fed me
loved me for we are after all simply one
world and one people
team flag smashers i'm sold
we're smashing flags tonight john
burning all my captain america gear
sorry for your loss i understand your
frustration i understand your
helplessness
so you want me to stop because people
are getting hurt right what if i'm
making the world a better place
that's not a better place if you're
killing people it's just different
you're either brilliant or just
hopelessly optimistic
[Music]
oh my god you care you're going to screw
this whole thing up
right now you're a supremacist
me yeah these corporations and the
beasts who run them they're the
supremacists
so you're killing innocent people
they're not innocent they're roadblocks
in my journey and i kill them again if
it
wow wow
you threw that one out there carly
morgenthau you're under arrest
carlos no i think we had enough time to
talk
oh bad idea oh
it's the american way
of course handcuffs
really it's all part of zmos playing
yeah
oh gosh that distant scream in the
background oh
zemo
oh no damn all that serum
[Music]
oh this is so bad there's so many people
in here who shouldn't have that
oh save one for walker
you could have murdered him just there
yeah oh i don't think he cares at all
not for zemo oh no he's gonna take it
there it is oh
no there's this one
[Applause]
ah the head tilt oh man
i'll tell you he's got like an
abomination thing about him he really
does yeah
battle star you got to keep your mana
check my dude
where you ever offered it what
super soldier no
super soldiers cannot be allowed
to exist isn't that how gods talk
what about bucky
blood isn't always the solution this
episode's like a battle of philosophies
yeah seriously i'm now ordering you to
turn him over i saw your role
and we're gonna need all hands on deck
for whatever's coming next how do you
want the rest of this conversation to go
sam
huh should i put down the shield
make it fair oh my god dude
captain slow your roll
oh damn here we go oh
here we go hi john walker
captain america
like i give a [ __ ] the door malaji don't
have jurisdiction here the dora milaj
have jurisdiction wherever the doormen
are refused
i think we got off on the wrong no don't
oh
[Music]
we should do something nah what's wrong
john
eyes pay attention come on watch the
road
how many times is this guy gonna just
slip away owie
that's his thing though man he riles
people
cool
wow yep
perfect aim
oh dude they just put you all in your
place dude
everyone's impotent oh i see some of the
wakanda detail in there
yeah that's cool they weren't even super
soldier
[Music]
oh you pitiful son of a [ __ ] damn
oh dude they're the most elite fighting
squad in the entire world
come on give cut yourself a break
you just start to feel like angry
and sad for this guy i know he's trying
so
hard he's got so much pressure on his
back
you call my sister that's how we gonna
play this sam i would
never hurt her i just wanted to
understand you better
i was going to ask you to join me or do
the world a favor and let me go
hey sam new cap is moving looks like
he's found them
maybe they found him
it's been a minute since we've seen the
wings
stealth my dude i think he took the
serum
yeah he's experiencing heightened senses
yeah he's hyper focused right now
yeah i think he's gonna murder those
guys
cool
oh yeah oh he took it yeah oh no oh
oh it's sam's gonna realize it did too
oh yeah
yep
you do so many cool like parkour jumps
with him
oh falcone yeah
oh by the kidneys
nice nicey
hug i love you captain america
oh no oh
walker's going to snap hey hey
hey hey come on come on one more
one more one more
oh this is this is an origin story
superhero landing attention filled
superhero land
oh my god
oh no
oh cap
oh
[Music]
how's that one woman just recording and
laughing with her friend what the hell
what
oh my god what
the hell murica
sweet diggity sweet diggity boy oh
boy good television god damn good tell
me i'm a good
tv damn good tv damn fine coffee damn
good
television humpty dumpty so many things
happening here
kind of confused where to begin you know
where i'll begin
um i love thematically everything this
series but particularly this episode
seems to be dealing so much with this
one theme about identity like we got so
much about
perspectives i feel is what we're
dealing with are constantly
looking for that gray and hey if the
show didn't trigger you i'm going to
trigger you now
this show's very political all right
keep your politics out of my political
show commentary
it's so politically commentary heavy
yeah
more than any mcu thing that i could
think of
right now off the top of my head yeah
because it has the time like it hints at
stuff like this
especially like winter soldier civil war
but you know you can really unpack it
here
well yeah this is like a lot of
conversations this was a battle of
philosophies throughout the whole tank
what's neat about it is while sometimes
it is very just relatable over things
like dealing with
people who are lower class or the
application of the word supremacists
things of that nature what i find
interesting is how they handle
perspectives it's kind of like in in
real life you know when you look at the
right and the left i've noticed they
kind of have similar opinions about each
other
yeah they each think the other side is
crazy they each see the other side is
out to destroy the world
and they remove the specific nouns but a
lot of the attitudes and behaviors are
quite similar
yeah well like you said the specificity
it often sounds like they're
they're having the same kind of basic
accusation
is what they're and that's kind of what
you get here especially in that scene
with carly
and falcon um when they're just having a
conversation with each other
sam just lets carly know you know some
people think you're a supremacist and
he's like no i'm going after the
supremacists
please no like i said themes of identity
and dealing with different perspectives
there's so much
wrapped up in here in in symbolism and
some stuff is like directly about
symbolism
and then other things are symbolic in
ways that
are not as on the nose and sometimes
they are you know like there's there's
there's so much commentary
happening in here playing a lot of
levels yeah
so much so that it's it's hard for me to
kind of
give a very focused train a thought
process here oh yeah
what to unpack because they're coming at
it from so many angles and they're yeah
coming at the whole thing of
it's hard to pin down any one
perspective because there are so many
ways to look at it and there's so many
also personal
things that fuel how people approach
other people outside of themselves and
whatnot
well they're dealing with the gray area
every which way like how falcon tells
tell carly
i agree with your fight i just don't
agree with the way you're going about
the fight
you know that's what i mean the gray
area and how the
i don't know his name the one who was
talking with carly earlier who said
that i used to look up to captain
america and i didn't view anyone else
like another cap until
you was something along those lines and
now he's even talking about
back then it was just good and bad and
now it's a little more complicated you
know
yeah now it's not really possible to do
the right thing without getting your
hands a bit dirty because that's the
arena now
yeah it's a battle of perspectives and
it's a battle of people who
think they're in the right one everybody
has a line at which they start looking
at other people is like well you know
those people that are just so far gone
that i can't afford to have any
consideration for them like when he
confronts about like you know all the
people that just got bombed in that last
episode
yeah and i think it's how we haven't
seen the power broker
either yet that's another one of those
latent themes that keeps being battered
around
is like the corruptive influence in
people's relationships to power
that's exactly what i was going to get
yeah exactly segway
said no no you're going to take it away
no yeah because that's
you know so like i love that bit
mirroring sam's response to zemo
and the hypothetical of would you take
the serum and yeah and the super soldier
serum like is literally doing that just
here's an allegory for
power corrupting people and people's
fight to either
not succumb to that or you know the sort
of
lies we sell ourselves in order to
justify taking up that power and i
thought that was a really interesting
thing with
carly having her explore that you know
because it makes a lot of sense for zemo
to be like yeah
nobody can willfully induce that
amount of power on themselves without
having some kind of view that they are
above
everyone else and yet you know carly
having this
globalist message of like no i'm just
the only one who kind of is willing to
do what needs to be done
it's super compelling i think it makes
it all the funnier that the power broker
is such a looming
presence when they've yet to show up
yeah in any capacity but they're like
so threatening to everyone who gets a
call or a text from them
well it's funny what the way the super
soldier serum is because i feel like in
any other show
or any other context it would just kind
of be a macguffin yeah absolutely but
it's not
you know it's an actual thing that's
really played in and lived in with the
world of the marvel cinematic universe
and even with carly when it comes to
power it's like they've lost
so much power because of the blip yeah
and everyone coming back they've lost so
much of what they had access to
and now in this fight against power
they're trying to regain power it's just
it is this
battle of who's who's allowed to be
in power and like i love that flip of
conversation
because sometimes it's sometimes in the
show in this particular episode it felt
like
am i listening to like a thesis paper or
a podcast of something so like
one division had one ship of theseus
scene let's just do an episode like that
in a sense yeah because there is so much
conversational stuff that i've often
that sounds like
just that a conversation it's not like
two people really debating an idea
it's not just like a big freaking high
stakes fully intense ev
there was something that i really found
refreshing about carly
and sam just like how she sits on the
table sitting across from him this
element of where they're
they start off distant and then slowly
they start to trust each other where
they're just standing across from one
another when they get more
like yeah relaxed even like she's just
kind of hunched over sitting on the
table and he's like leaning against it
you know like they eventually
yeah get comfortable even yeah his
relatability quality
and it's zemo talking with sam too
about why there should be no more super
soldier serums and why this shouldn't be
out in the world and like zemar just
hates anything
that is above human yeah basically
but in order to eliminate that isn't
that the mentality of a god too like oh
what itself is that's a great flip yeah
yeah
what a wonderful flip the way they were
capturing john walker and again going
back to the sense of power and
perspective like
john walker was actually the ultimate
symbolism for all of it
let's face it they put this guy in a
position that he just cannot fulfill
and it's not really his fault i mean
it's not like
at the end of the day it takes more than
super soldier serum to be captain
america
absolutely to be steve rogers absolutely
i was talking about the beginning of
this discussion
showing the opposites and some overt
symbolism and some stuff was a little
bit more subtle
like steve was chosen for super soldier
serum because who he was
internally and they talk about how power
will only amplify who this person really
is this perspective that lamar has of
john walker as
this like great guy yeah and the dude
who makes the right
choice yeah that's gotta look up to you
when i got my back
when you know like well i mean you're
kind of so
in it that you don't really see exactly
who john walker wanted to be
yeah the more forgiving of that cause
you know him so well
100 i love that how he
steve rogers gets the serum because of
how the good person he is
and then becomes captain america and
this guy kind of has this backwards
journey steve rogers yeah it's like
here's the great person that you are
that allows you to become the excellent
soldier whereas this is like here's the
excellent soldier
that we're just gonna take and sort of
elevate without much consideration for
the other part without the appreciation
that comes with
not having just that pedigree you know
and the way they were capturing his
because he's a person who's trying to
control the situation lamar and john
walker
arrive they they find zemo i thought it
was so stupid how
honestly i thought i was done like john
walker just walk around as captain
america like come on dude
at least have some kind of stealth
costume i know he's recognizing
everything but for
the the city that is like don't trust
him don't trust him don't you trust them
like maybe
walking around just captain america
and like no one's listening to him he's
trying to assert his dominance he's
trying to demonstrate the power position
that he's in but you got to earn that
leadership position you got to earn that
trust you got to earn that influence
he's earned none of it he's kind of just
demanding and expecting it to happen but
no one
other than lamar trusts him every step
of the way and then he makes his own
calls and it
backfires significantly like i said
earlier it's not his fault why he's in
this position in order to go up against
what he has to go up against
you can't just be a regular human with a
captain america shielded you don't
battle yeah
guys what were you thinking putting just
a normal you even if he is exceptionally
human he's still just a human
you need something extra dude you're
setting this man up for
failure every step of the way like i
don't blame him for the path he went
down with choosing to take the serum
especially in the position that he's in
and he's the successor
to the man who had the super soldiers
here
it makes sense that he would want it
especially with the mission center only
going against all these other people
he needs it to to regain some control
but
obviously like this demonstration that
he's of when he murders that guy
and the public is watching i'm just like
where where's the show going to go now
where's go where the hell is this going
to go they're in it
soil the opening shots of the next
episode are just going to be every news
channel carrying
that footage there's no way to go back
from that he murdered a flag smasher
what does this lead to
i like i have no idea what this is going
to lead to a war is it going to lead to
more of the world siding with the flag
smashers as they were talking about on
the news earlier how they were growing a
following
it's probably just gonna make the divide
on both sides that much
deeper yeah it's gonna solidify the flag
smashers sympathy that much more
and also the authoritarian sympathy that
much more
like that was a brutal scene and i love
the way how when they were cutting back
and forth
when uh he was getting impatient waiting
so he could bust in on carly it had this
alejandro and narito
kind of super like exposed darkly
lit incredibly hand held frantic
crispy frame rate yeah just like oh
you're there and it's icky and like you
can just feel the sweat
just showing how i'm trying to win
i'm not moving fast enough i need
results lamar and john walker are a
different version
of captain america and falcon the
mirroring that this episode does
like where falcon is like no i want to
take the super soldier serum
no hesitation at all and then you cut to
lamar i was like yeah dude of course
here's why
you know battle of perspectives again
battle of philosophies
everyone is trying to control the
situation and i love when the dora
milanese show up because
all them lose power i have no moment and
so literally too like you know bucky
gets his arm taken away cap gets a
shield taken away
well with bucky what i loved about the
performance of when his arm got taken
away
he didn't know about that yeah it's
almost as if he wasn't trusted
yeah yeah absolutely it's a fail safe we
giveth we take it away
yeah so that's that was like a neat
little body language moment that didn't
need to be said but you could feel it
all in the it's an interesting
compliment
from the first scene in wakanda with io
where she is helping him move past
the brainwashing yeah the trigger word
the trigger words
the the the activation words that make
him go full on winter soldier and he's
having to just
power through it and eventually he has
the breakthrough and
in that moment where he's just really
crying like i don't recall
seeing sebastian stan deliver this level
of
gravitas and any of the movies
like full-on body language act like even
though there's dialogue the whole scene
is pretty much just about
body language and the intensity of the
connection between them and the trust
that they have to go through
like feeling like the fire too is uh
illuminating a lot of the rage within
him
or it could be symbolic for like burning
it up
you know yeah yeah burning up the last
ashes of the programming
and how it breaks through this look of
hope and then to have their final scene
in this episode be one of mistrust
when the first scene is something of
trust this last one was well we didn't
in case you know yeah you know
we also did trust you with eight hours
worth of time
try and get your thing across well in
that scene too where uh the the
case pops open and all the serums hit
the floor like i thought it was
it was cool because you have two like
really impactful character moments out
of one little set piece because like
zemo crushing them is such a huge like
they did a good job i think of you said
before it seems like it could have just
been a macguffin
but in that moment i was like oh damn
but these are like the only ones left
and so if zemo crushes them all that's
it you know and so you have almost that
but then you know john walker's gonna
get one but either way you see
two like huge amplifications of both
characters out of that moment
it's really fascinating i love how
they've honed in on the super soldier's
serum to
let it be a demonstration of power you
know
john walker a person who is top tier
government agent
soon to be u.s agent top tier you're
going to get a lateral promotion
top-tier government agent right
dependent on the super soldier serum
and then you got flag smashers people
who come essentially from
poverty who are essentially shunned who
rely on the super soldiers here
you know like two opposite ends who are
both relying on the same thing
yeah for two totally different
philosophies and two totally different
agendas yeah it paints it all in a
different
light but yeah like with the super
soldier serum in some ways it's going to
show zemo's right
yeah this shouldn't just be getting
distributed and people shouldn't be
getting made
you know because look at the chaos it
causes absolutely once you open that box
it's really hard to close it
yeah and like that line of how many
steve rogers are there
and even he gave up he was like touched
but also we have the yeah have there
been any others since
it's a fascinating conversation i guess
i love this one because
how conversational it was there are
times to get some
like some criticism and some nitpicks
out of the way there are times where i
was
feeling like i'm being told a lot
instead of just letting it be lived in
like how they're talking about what the
world during the blip was like
and how there's this uprising in
flagsmaster support how rob these people
like carly and her people are
like i feel like the greater context of
the flag smashers gets put into
exposition like that rather than
actually getting to show it to us
yeah exactly you know and i'm like well
how much time do they really have and
could they really just go around show it
as one other stuff
just the flagship life and maybe we will
get that but
there are times where i'm like this
would have a better impact if it was
more shown instead of a lots being told
to me i get why falcon
feels or sam really feels uh
for what the flag smasher's cause is and
what the flag smashers are fighting for
since he's been personally affected by
similar circumstances in the position
that he's been in it's just as sam
wilson not his falcon
back in his own hometown i get it but
there are times where i'm like i'm being
told a lot of what the world is like i
just kind of want to see
some of the world or feel a little bit
more forward instead of being told
what some of it is i still like it and
and i'm also
on the end of well most of these
characters we're hanging out with
weren't around other people like carly
but a lot of the people like
for sam's perspective and bucky they
weren't around they were gone for five
years
so the way they're learning about it is
through
being fed information yeah so it makes
sense
yeah yeah yeah so like i get it i guess
my main criticism is actually
the double beat of zemo escaping that
could be a nitpick but the second time
he got away i was like
come on i mean he's so oily so on the
one hand i'm like i guess that's just a
thing is like if you put him someplace
and take your eyes off of him i feel
like twice in one episode is a little
much
uh but i did i guess especially
appreciate how the second time went
downwards just like
everybody because like that's so the
essence of zemo is to just get everybody
riled up into some kind of alternate
conflict so that i could just slip right
out and do my own thing and so yeah
but he didn't cause that no that's true
it just happened
and both times he escaped for what he
was escaped was just happened by chance
that all the people
are grounded abstract and everyone's
like arrest emo we are going to keep our
eyes on zemo and then
everyone gets distracted like slip it
away
yeah yeah yeah and there was also the
thing of like you know you knew
john walker was going to come in on him
and carly at the exact right
wrong moment yeah and i think the only
thing that saved that for me was the
fact that they still
kept the connection of what sam was able
to earn there i feel like maybe a
different show might not have done that
at all
bothering for the second meetup and
contacting his sister so that made that
at least a little more interesting
i love wyatt russell's performance
absolutely
it's really gripping i feel like one
thing that shows in the last couple
episodes is actually kind of lost sight
of
is the falcon and the winter soldier
yeah like not them as individuals but
them as a duo
yeah or becoming a team or becoming a
duo it's there
having them feel like the center of it
though there's so many other characters
and circumstances
yeah at the end of the day when
everyone's like [ __ ] doing their own
thing or betraying people or whatever
they're still together yeah they are
right down at the very end where where
bucky does say i'm gonna go with you
to the meeting with carly at the end
like i'll be there to help you or
or be his backup like yeah that's there
but
i find myself more interested in all the
other
entangl like really the part of the show
that's not as interesting to me anymore
is bucky and sam together it's
everything else
yeah and i mean for the way the first
couple episodes started out you know
these circumstances
don't necessarily i guess factor in when
you're dealing with flag smashers and
all that but the first episode was so
personal with what sam was going through
in his own life and what bucky was
dealing with with his redemption path
and everything and
you know they're on the mission now and
so it feels like all that stuff is just
kind of
gone for the moment part of me is sort
of spoiled in a sense because i i do
feel like the episodes have
taken some interesting turns in terms of
not focusing so much on the action you'd
expect but like here getting into the
philosophy and
and you know really diving into that and
now i'm sitting here on the heels of
that going okay now if we could just get
some more character moments for bucky
and sam and then maybe some of those
like
you know real world impact flag smasher
ideology
type moments to really make this feel
rich at the core
you know like i feel like that could
nudge it over the line into greatness
do you know what i just realized what
that is
in uh captain america civil war the shot
where cap has a moment where he looks
like he he's about to kill iron man and
he raises his shield
and just lodges into the iron man suit
but doesn't kill him
he chose not to not to go in for his
caps to see rogers
yeah he chose to let go that his own
personal rage
that moment replicated uh shot sequence
wise
and style there were framing devices of
it that were
kind of akin to that moment in civil war
and said he uses
it to [ __ ] smash this guy to death he
chooses
his own personal vendetta over the
actual whole
situation they really did a great job i
thought in this particular episode
demonstrating how
he is nothing like steve rogers even
though he
so badly wants to be and intends to be
yeah you know like and that's the other
thing too is
is the fascinating uh nuance of how
badly you can
want to fulfill an ideology but maybe
you don't quite understand that ideology
or maybe just your own
ideology isn't actually in line with
that and there's so many
intricate things that can make that so
and yeah it's
fascinating to watch john walker play
that stuff out i really think
like at an earlier stage in mcu or any
or any other less show
they would have just played him
straightforward evil but that's like you
could really feel this guy
he really just wants to do a good job
and the reason he turned to killing was
because
someone he loves was just killed yeah
and the only person who had his back
the only like one positive source in his
life yeah
the only a person he loved died so he
was hurt
that's what i mean it's so human yeah
it's not like just i'm evil i want the
super soldier
you know yeah i need to become america
number one and badass
it's it's so much more layered and yeah
i really admire this episode a hell of a
lot
and also for io i think that's really
cool
cause i was barely in the movies like
she's
barely in it yeah i had to jog my memory
for a couple minutes be like wait oh
yeah she's the one
who said move or you'll be moved or
something like that in civil war when we
watched the episode last week i
recognized her from like which one was
yeah that's right
to see her get a chance to become a
full-on character here and to see how
important like it's crazy to know she
was one of the people right by
t'challa's side
when they were hunting down the winter
soldier in civil war to grow to such a
point to progress to such a point where
she's actually the one who helped free
him yeah
to disarm him completely and to send him
back into the world rehabilitated
like it provides more impact and
importance on her character that i'm
wondering like oh i'm going back to
civil war might
make the viewing experience just a
little bit different knowing just how
significant her character has become
yeah that's just a great opportunity for
the actors too i think that's awesome oh
yeah
yeah i hope we get more with her and i
mean any surprise visit from the door
melanche is a good thing in my book
yeah because that was an awesome fight
scene too it was an awesome fight and
there were there were fights that were
my like a lot of the stairwell chasing
fight scenes reminded me a lot of civil
war
in some ways i feel like this show is
almost a direct sequel the civil war
except the infinity war end game
happened in between
yeah but it seems like that's the main
context yeah
it seems like the yeah the main context
to be aware of is the captain america
movies
and then mainly it seems to be a sequel
to that yeah but then the world of
post end game is is the biggest effect
yeah now that this
huge world-changing event has happened
what now captain america but it seems
like this is captain america four
yeah yeah yeah it feels that way i think
why i like this one the most
is because it's just doing all the
things that i was hoping it would do
it's not shying away from the
conversations
whether which side you agree with or not
this felt very
dark the violence hits
and i think this would feel like a true
cinematic experience
as a binge you know like i've noticed
that it just gets grittier and grittier
and darker
unlike one division which actually i
think would work better week to week
and i thought it worked great week to
week falcon winter soldier there's
something about the way it's playing out
that feels like
one big movie yeah if i went back to
re-watch this i could definitely be
see myself going you know let me just
power through yeah yeah
i was going to watch one or two but now
i'm 100 yeah all right guys well
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell
hit that like button thanks to eric for
editing the highlights of the reaction
for us
and last but not least
jason dolan yes um i want to shout out
jason dolan
because if there's anyone who
looks like john walker at our patreon
can you imagine jason with his head
crunched into that little helmet i can't
i can't too it's funny
perpetual five o'clock shadow but jason
nolan
you know for sure mm-hmm that's
america's ass on jason
it would be so funny it will work i
think it would totally work you look
like the kind of guy that'd be like
hey you're the new cat you you
you look like a classic all-american
young lad come over here john walker
yeah you're the all-american way you're
the spirit symbol of peace and
and justice and all that stuff hey jd i
love you man
you're like an amazing [ __ ] human
being you've been there for me countless
times
and um yeah you know uh i think you
if you had the opportunity to take this
super soldier serum i think you totally
would take it you would take it
you would absolutely take it you should
and then you'd convince me for a half
hour of me saying no
why not to and i all right fine i guess
i'm taking the superstar
jason called me up he talked me into it
let me talk
let me get word at a certain point just
to get him off the phone
it didn't occur to me till after i could
just lied about taking it but whatever
now i got all these extra powers you
don't even
look up your shout outs so we can say
whatever you want you have a shirt here
yeah yeah that's right sure for three
years let's make it five
ten tenth anniversary jason jason i'm
sure i'll be seeing you soon
[Music]